good morning John it's Monday sometime
in the end of September the MacBook
tells me if the 29th today because I'm
having a rather bad hair day and the
entire world is having a rather bad
financial day I think I'm gonna try and
take care of both of those things by
explaining the recent financial crisis
the number of different hats on my head
representing exactly who I am at the
time when I'm talking hi my name is
William I want alone can I have one in
the past we only gave one to people who
could pay the amount of the loan but now
since the cost of your house is just
gonna keep going up and up and up we've
decided that were pretty much gonna give
everybody alone for whatever month they
want and they don't have to actually
prove that they'll be able to pay it off
oh cool that's actually really good for
me because I don't have a really good
job and I couldn't really afford the
mortgage payments who do we have a deal
for you check this out we'll give you
like no mortgage payments for like two
years and you wanted to pay any loans at
all you just it's free it's like a free
house oh my god two years well in two
years I'll probably be like the CEO of
my company and my house will obviously
be worth like 50% more so what am I
really concerned about here nothing you
have nothing to worry about at all
here's your loan thank you
boy am i God I don't actually have to
secure that loan I'll just send it off
to the bank and they'll have some
solution for what to do with this crappy
loan that I just made meanwhile at the
bank we're giving out a lot of loans but
we're not seeing a lot of income from
those loans but we need to give out more
loans
so what do we do how do we get more
capital so we can give more bad loans
well I think I have an idea for us how
about we do this we take the loans that
we've got and then we sell them we sell
them as assets we say these loans are
going to be paid back and if they're not
then the houses that they're on will be
worth way more in the end anyway
and so the loans will have a great deal
of work we'll sell them off and people
will buy them up like hotcakes
and they'll be so excited and here's an
idea we'll give them different names so
the bad mortgages will name triple-a it
will say that they're the best of the
bad mortgages and then the really bad
mortgages will name triple B which
sounds way better than really really bad
mortgages and then the ones that stink
like L
been diarrhea on a hot day we'll just
not name those ones at all and give
people really great interest rates on
those securities oh my god that kind of
sounds like a good idea so people just
buy them and then we'll get more money
so we can load more money out but wait a
second if the bad market is all turn out
to be bad
are we just screwing ourselves I mean
yeah we end up making more money in the
short term because we can make a loan
and then make money on that loan by
selling the loan but in the long term
are we gonna be screwed oh you have the
wrong vision you see you're looking into
the future
what you need to do is think about next
quarter because that's what our
investors are thinking about you need to
think about how much money we will be
making in the immediate future thinking
two or three years down the line is not
something we do here in the financial
sector
and besides housing prices will always
go up and if not the government will be
there to catch us why would the
government be there to catch us who
because my friend if we go down the
country goes down don't worry they'll be
there two years later oh I can't pay
this mortgage payment and my house is
worth way less honest let me get my
calculator done I knew it my mortgage is
worth way more than my house is I get
default on my mortgage and then get
another mortgage and get away better
house for the same price
I'm totally gonna stop paying these
mortgage payments back at the bank hello
hello my name is Jeremy Hoegaarden I
bought a bunch of your mortgage-backed
securities and I've recently discovered
that they are worth absolutely nothing
what the Frick is going on well that's
well as I was running inconvenience as
lots of people bought them in fact
people bought the matarese I drove the
economy all across the world and and
it's possible that we may have triggered
a somewhat of a tiny massive global
recession very sorry working on it right
now we'll get back to you please do not
call again bye